>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Next we have Nick Adams, a
sociologist and research fellow
at the Berkeley Institute
for Data Science.
He's going to talk about how social
scientists use the congressional
record as a data source.
Welcome, Nick.
>> Nick Adams: Hello, hello.
Library of Congress, archivists,
librarians, journalists, data nerds,
fellow social scientists
and digital humanists.
I'm very honored to be here today.
This is really exciting for me,
kind of a mecca for someone like me.
I've done a lot of work with a lot
of textural data and to be able
to speak here is truly an honor.
For many of us, archives
evoke images
of old leather-bound books
[inaudible] sweet acrid odors
of oxidizing pulp, and
they arouse the excitement
of discovering some
long lost history
as though it were a buried treasure.
But my particular excitement
about archives is a bit different.
Like all of my fellow
scholars, I swoon at the thought
of uncovering old worlds and
newspapers or policy tracks,
meeting minutes, contracts
or even receipts.
These are the sort of documents
that most people throw away
with the recycling, but we
really cherish these data
as unspoiled records
of human behavior.
They tell the stories of
who we were economically,
politically, socially
and culturally.
So I want to first say thank you to
all the librarians and archivists
who make this data available.
It really allows us to do our work.
And we completely depend on you.
So in the way that I can't
because I only have two hands,
can you all help me
give a round of applause
to the people that make this happen?
[ Applause ]
A little louder.
Okay. Maybe I should end there
some people might be thinking.
I said everything that
needs to be said.
But like I said, there's
a little more --
my love for archives is a
bit different than typical
because I think archives can
be far more powerful than most
of my fellow scholars have yet
imagined, and I want to show all
of you to the extent I can how
we can bring about a future
where archives are used much more
often and much more intensively
to give us much deeper
understanding of human behavior.
So right now central scientists
and digital humanists are
at the beginning of what I see
as a decade long process of kind
of updating the way we work
with documentary evidence.
We're learning to read
right along side computers.
We're beginning to understand and
trust how they can read differently
and much faster than we can
and find patterns in minutes
that we really couldn't find
without months of close reading.
So there's a bunch
of new computational text analyst
approaches that people can use.
We can [inaudible]
sentences by grammar.
We can find named entities
like people and locations.
We can model topics of what people
are talking about across documents.
We can model networks of
individuals and how they relate.
We can even do really kind of thing
that a classical qualitative
ethnographic research
like grounded theory with
the assistance of computers.
There's so much we can do right now,
but these powerful tools
require very different ways
of organizing collections
and that's what I really want
to talk about today.
So most of us here are familiar with
traditional practices of archiving,
the preservation, organization,
maintenance and the careful control
and protection of documents and
from the researcher's standpoint,
when we want to pull an
archive, we consult a librarian
who helps us pull the
records and then we look
at the documents usually
one document
at a time often wearing gloves or
viewing through some pane of glass.
And these archives
are really helpful.
They allow us to ask
important specific questions
of specific documents, questions
like what happened when,
did he or she really say or do that?
Who paid whom?
And who voted which
way on which bill?
But all of this kind of research,
these questions are all kind
of a forensic style of
research where we're looking
for particular details at
a particular date occurring
in a particular document.
But now we've entered this
age of digitalization.
So what's new?
What's different?
Obviously, no archivist or
librarian would want me to thumb
through their most aged
and cherished records
at 40 pages per second,
applying an array
of highlighter colors
directly to the collections.
I can hear some of you like
wincing at the thought.
But that sort of thing can really
easily be done with digital records.
So how is that going
to change research
and how are we going
to adapt to that?
Exciting. So did we go too fast?
We went past.
Oh, there it goes.
Okay. So there are some
digital archiving products
that are really plowing forward.
So chronicling America, a
bunch of people have mentioned,
is allowing researchers
to skim through thousands
of newspapers using
digital approaches.
And in this talk series
a while back,
Matthew Weber's archives
unleash program was discussed,
and it's generating valuable
findings hacking away
at what he has called
well curated archives,
but these are not really the norm.
Actually, what's normal
is quite a bit different.
As Elizabeth Lorang mentioned
during her talk in this series,
one of the most prominent challenges
cited by respondents in their use
of digital collections was the
inability to search effectively
through the collection materials,
and this is really common.
To give you an example, the
government publishing office --
the GPO website has a lot of really
impressive holdings describing the
activities of our government, the
congressional record, hearings,
all kinds of votes, and these data
are really essential to democracy
and to the GPO's mission of
keeping America informed.
The data are really valuable.
They're important.
They're totally available to
the public, which is great,
and they're even digitized
in an ideal kind
of machine readable format.
Yet, they're extremely difficult
to research using this state
of art text analysis
techniques that I just discussed.
Let me give you a sense
of what that looks like.
Here's a GPO website.
So if I wanted to understand how
my congress person is dealing
with science, I could go
to a particular congress.
I could go to the house hearings.
I could look for the committee
on science and technology
and then I could read the text of
every last committee hearing and try
to follow along with what my
congress person was doing.
So we select a file, we
read it in the viewer,
in this case a web browser, and
we view it without touching it,
without labeling it, without
scribbling on it and we have
to take our notes in
the separate document.
So in a lot of ways, even though
this text is fully digital,
we're still wearing the gloves.
We're still looking at a document
from behind a pane of glass.
Now to be clear, I don't believe
this is the state of affairs
because archivists are
somehow over protective
or uninterested or just ornery.
Maybe some of you are.
But this is a very well
organized set of links
that makes perfect sense for
human looking for information
about a particular hearing.
And we organize our
digital records this way,
the same way we would
organize our physical records
because these systems are so
sensible for traditional research
and so expedient for
archivist's fundamental tasks
of preservation and publication.
So if we don't want to
click and click and click
and download each file, what
do social scientists want?
I know this is the
question of Washington.
Every funding conversation,
every policy conversation.
What do the social scientists want?
I can dream.
Well, we want data that
are well structured.
That's what we want.
And I'll have a slide in a moment
that kind of lays that out.
But let me offer you a sense
just through some examples.
Perhaps we want to
see all the materials
in the congressional record or
it could be for any archive,
we want to see all the materials
that are authored by men or women
or people from this or
that geographic region.
All instances we're
[inaudible] particular phrase
like interstate commerce and
the date of the utterance.
Who said it?
The district they represent if we're
looking at the congressional record.
Even adjectives that are marshalled
to describe particular nouns
like veteran, teacher,
doctor or child.
How are these people described?
Perhaps I want to assess the
comfort of congress members
with the scientific process.
So I want to do some sort of search,
and this is just a little
bit pseudo code here.
I want to see if I
can find all instances
where people say the word hypothesis
or falsify, correlation, causation,
statistical significance
and if I find that,
then I want to see the speech
displayed along with the idea
of the speaker, the
identification of the speaker,
the party they're associated
with, etc. That would be --
that would be really nice, and
I'd be able to kind of compare
across the entire congressional
record how people are talking
about science.
But that's not really
what we have right now.
That's just not possible on the
government publishing office
and those sorts of questions
that dig into both the metadata
and the content of the text itself
are not really possible right now.
So we can't search all the text
of all the science hearings.
We can't easily identify particular
speeches and speakers even though
as a reader, if I read
through that document,
I know when member Jones is speaking
and when member Smith is speaking.
And I can't immediately know
the party identification
of the person even though this
is really common knowledge.
This stuff is not actually
connected to the data right there
as a researcher when
I want to query it.
So what do social scientists
do with archives like the GPO?
Well, the answer is not much
because it's just too hard to look
through all that data one document
at a time or to learn all the skills
to figure out how to
bring it together
so that you can search it the
way you want to search it.
But I'm here today -- that's
[inaudible] the talk either.
We don't have to sigh and walk
away with our heads held down.
I'm here to talk about an effort
that's trying to help change that --
the Capitol Query Project.
So a few years ago, I founded the
computational text analysis working
group at UC Berkeley.
And a key [inaudible] of
that group's mention was
to not just teach researchers
how to fish,
but to teach a research
team how to whale.
No marine mammals have been
harmed just so you know.
But to teach a research
team how to organize --
how to do the massive amount of work
necessary to acquire clean process,
analyze, interpret and report
on massive textual archives.
Now we're partnering
with the Goodly Labs
and the Social Science
Research Council
so that we can not only convert the
government publishing office data
into a queriable record
of what congress is up to,
but also so that we can create
tutorials showing anyone how
to do this for their
own digital collections.
I just want to recognize some
of my teammates here quickly
before I say a little bit more
about the project.
And any of you could
join this slide.
We'll talk about that later.
So here's a project in pictures.
First thing we're going to do is
we're going to gather all the data,
all the documents across all
those links into one place.
And then next, we're finding and
labeling structures in the text.
So maybe we're looking for
particular speech acts or events
or locations or ad hoc groups,
and we can add that structure
to the text through
annotations through XML.
And then we take the existing
structure that was already there
with the newly created
structure, and link it into --
with external data sources
that enable us to --
that enable powerful
queries answering questions
that we couldn't even ask before.
So let me say a little bit about
well structured research ready data.
That's the hard product of this
project is to create a database,
and for the record, we should now
what well structured research ready
data looks like.
First of all, it should
be digital text.
It should be machine readable
so that a computer can look
for different tokens and compare
across various different documents.
It should be queriable with that
token search but also across a set
of documents that the
researcher has defined.
So if they want everything from
Arizona or they want everything
from a decade, should be able
to look at that immediately.
This is really important and
a lot of people when they move
into a digital archive
and then they try
to make it public,
they make this mistake.
It's really important to
retain the original structure
and formatting of the documents.
So I'm going to ding proquest here.
I don't think anyone's
going to be too upset.
Proquest takes a congressional
record, and they strip it
of all the white space,
all the new line characters
and the paragraph breaks, and
these subheadings that help us read
through the document and understand,
oh, this is just the table
of contents or this is a
portion where they're going
to do some prematter, but
they're not really talking
about the hearing yet.
It's important to retain
the original structure
that the original authors used
to keep track of which portions
of the text are doing what
sort of conceptual work.
And then as much as possible, we
want to add in some supplemental
and searchable annotations on
the text, things like I said,
looking for speech acts or speakers
or locations, etc. And finally,
we want to be able to link
the data to other data
that describe the same objects.
So that hearing document is going
to talk about congress member Smith,
but there's a lot I know
about congress member Smith
in another database that tells me
about her age and her district,
population and demographics
of her district,
which might actually influence
the way she's behaving.
So in all of this, we're not just
creating a queriable database,
but there's a huge learning
opportunity here for anyone
that wants to take their digital
archive and make it more accessible
to a larger audience of
researchers and the public.
So we're going to be creating
a kind of step by step how
to guide with tutorial notebooks.
We'll be using Jupyter
notebooks which allow us to write
in plain English what we're
doing right next to a cell
that runs executable code.
So for all those of you who are
a little afraid of programming,
the idea is to take you step by step
through the process of doing this.
So phase one, gathering the data
together, phase two, finding
and adding structure to
it and then phase three,
linking it to other useful data.
To dig into these a
little bit, in phase one,
bring all your data together,
this is just trying to get
around pointing, clicking and
downloading a thousand times.
And so we can actually
train a computer to do this
or we can train people to
tell a computer how to do it.
So we'll be turning people in these
notebooks to use regular expressions
to use [inaudible] so that
they can look on a website
and with a web browser automation
tool like [inaudible] instead
of doing all that pointing
and clicking yourself,
you can have a computer
do it for you.
Phase two is really
where were trying to move
from the current state of the art,
which is kind of a
craft to a science.
Finding structure in texts is --
it takes a lot of working back
and forth with the text, knowing
what is theoretically important
that you're trying to find there,
and then using the computer
to help you find that structure
to chunk it out, to label it
and to add structure
where there wasn't before.
So we take people through the
very basics of regular expressions
and how to use XML, and we show them
some of the text analysis techniques
that I talked about at
the top of the talk,
and we're even using crowdsource
annotation software called text
[inaudible] which is
also a technology created
by the Goodly Labs.
All of these things allow
us to get the humans
and the computers together working
to find that structure in the text.
And then in order to do
this really efficiently
with a programming script, you need
to know some basic programming
architecture that's not super hard
to learn but we'll teach it.
Finally in phase three, phase three
is about linking all of that data.
So it's identifying
relevant data sources,
effectively structuring
your database
so that you're anticipating the
queries of the research community
and you're also reducing
redundancies in the data storage.
Paul who spoke just before me
really kind of set this up.
If we can use SQL and
relational databases,
we can compute much more
quickly over some of this sort
of multilayered structured text.
So to close really, I just want to
ask you all to get research ready.
We'll be pushing some of this
out in November, and we're hoping
that people will give us
feedback and let us know
like your phase one
tutorials were great.
Your phase two tutorials
were quite confusing,
and you need to go back
to the drawing board.
We're really looking for engagement
from the Library of Congress
and any libraries or archives or
researchers who are interested
in getting in on this, and I
don't know if they cut me off,
but it seems they cut me off.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah. So if you'd like
to join in this effort
or follow along, here
are some links.
What I was going to show you
if I could is the entire project
is completely open to the public.
You can go to the open
society framework that's hosted
by the Center for Open
Science and you can watch
and follow along with our project.
If you want to jump in, you can
actually go to our [inaudible] page
and just start doing pull requests.
That would be exciting, although
feel free to contact us first
and maybe we can lead you
to the work that's most
pressing at the moment.
But I really appreciate everything
that everyone in this room is doing,
and I'm really looking
forward to getting to this kind
of blue sky space in the future.
So help us out as you can.
Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.